dans le nord-est de l'Ukraine des
paysages qui ne trompent pas une terre
qui porte l'empreinte de la guerre la
mort et la destruction dans toutes les
directions
seul protection ici les tranchées que
nous fait visiter Sania non guerre
hayakax
dangereux chaque minute chaque seconde
dit-il tout change très vite
il explique que tout le monde sur la
ligne de France Satan une grande
offensive russe mais les Ukrainiens sont
prédit-il on ne va pas les laisser
passer
la vie offrant se déroule beaucoup sous
terre pour se protéger se réchauffer
meublé latente souvent interminable
entre les missions mais ici le conflit
entre dans sa deuxième année Nicolas et
lui n'a pas vu le temps passer
tout est allé très vite dit-il l'été
l'automne l'hiver est presque terminé
maintenant on a éteint nos cerveau et on
fait notre travail
nous sommes ici en première ligne les
positions russes ne sont qu'à 3 km d'ici
dans cette direction et ça tire tous les
jours
[Musique]
si elle a parfois des apparences de
Première Guerre mondiale avec ses
tranchées la guerre d'Ukraine est aussi
très moderne les combats ici se
déroulent souvent par écran interposé
nous sommes dans le poste de
commandement du 225e bataillon de la
127e brigade de défense territoriale
un emplacement
de sécurité
les services de renseignement ont
localisé un dépôt d'armes au thé russe
le commandant ukrainien mieux connu sous
son nom de guerre circo et bien décidé à
le détruire pour faire dérailler
l'offensive ennemi les coordonnées sont
transmises au poste de tir au quartier
général on observe le résultat en direct
sur grand écran
mission accomplie
mondiale les tactiques russes n'ont pas
changé dit-il elles sont basées sur
l'envoi massif de Shera canon l'armée
ukrainienne est aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus mobile plus flexible et plus
inventive selon lui nous l'aurez figeons
beaucoup plus de dommages que l'inverse
ajoute-t-il
le commandant olegara à la rencontre des
hommes qui ont mené à bien l'attaque
pour les féliciter une mission
d'artillerie confie à un équipage de
tente un usage inhabituel ici on fait
avec ce que l'on a en l'occurrence avec
un vieux t64 de l'air soviétique non je
crois que il a été fabriqué à carque
différemment Léonides sont commandant
mais le temps qui se l'avoue son
véhicule n'est plus tout jeune aussi
tous ici attendent avec impatience les
chars et blindé occidentaux
les Léopards de allemands comme ce
premier par le Canada nos hommes
apprennent vite dit-il donnez-nous les
et on s'occupe du reste
tous ici non donc aucun doute sur
l'issue de la guerre une victoire
ukrainienne car l'inverse est impensable
quant au calendrier du style il dépendra
fortement des armes recevront et de
leurs dates de livraison ici
Jean-François Bélanger Radio-Canada près
de la ligne de France dans le nord-est
de l'Ukraine